president Trump is he there yes no ap
live television yes or no I am I'm right
here
mr. president thank you I apparently I
heard you in the press conference yeah
you had a 9:00 p.m. call with with
President Xi of China let me start there
how does that go well because of you I
made it at 10:30 so that just shows you
the number one rated show on television
I better check things right now I mean
I'm talking to him at 10:30 right after
this call I'll be talking to you know
one thing I will say i watch the task
force watching you and it takes a lot of
energy stamina and you never stop being
president let me ask you I remember when
I interviewed you at mar-a-lago for the
Super Bowl I don't know if you remember
me asking the question I asked you to
tell me how did you in the first known
case of Corona was January 21st ten days
later you instituted a travel ban Joe
Biden called you xenophobic astareal and
a fear monger good walk us through that
decision because you said to me nobody
supported it well you know we had 20
people in the office 21 to be exact
and we had a lot of experts and they
never really thought to do that and you
know I passed a travel ban having to do
with our country if we have certain
unsafe countries countries that we think
are unsafe if you remember I passed and
we won in the Supreme Court we lost in
the lower courts and we won in the
Supreme Court so we have a travel ban
throughout the world if we want if we
have unsafe countries terrorism etc etc
so I said well wait a minute these
people if they're badly infected and
they are very badly because I was
starting to see stories and you were and
everybody was I said how many come in
well we had massive amounts coming into
the country if you look at it thousands
and thousands a day and I said look we
shouldn't be doing this I made a
decision we can't have it and people
thought it was very tough some of my own
people I can't be honest with you China
didn't think it was too good either and
I think we're just absolutely fine with
them
the people decided to go to Italy
instead they went to Spain instead and
you see the problems they're having even
the smaller countries by comparison you
see the problems having but I made that
decision which I'm very proud of in
retrospect and you're right I had Biden
calling me a xenophobic and yet he can't
define the word of us - what does it
mean I'm sure he couldn't tell you what
it means and I had him he called me a
racist because of the fact that he felt
it was a racist thing to stop people
from China coming in but that was from
the section of China - that was in such
trouble so we made a good decision and
if we didn't would have thousands and
thousands of more people in very serious
trouble right now mr. mr. president I've
been making the case this is everything
that's going on now we're rewriting the
book how to deal with pandemics you
started with the travel ban and the
quarantine and then it the
public-private partnership which we
should talk about all the great
companies we have in this country drive
through testing now we'll have a 15
minute test soon in the doctor's office
we'll have home testing we're told
according to your task force soon
telemedicine I would argue is probably
one of the easier solutions for
healthcare off-label use getting rid of
draconian FDA rules right to try vaccine
we're in stage one trials it used to
take years to break down the sequence
tell us about what's changing and why it
has to all change well I think the FDA
has been incredible we have a man
Stephen on who's a doctor great doctor
highly respected from Texas in charge of
one of the great hospitals of our world
and he came in as the FDA director and
we had a good man there before also as
you know Scott you know Scott very well
and we we've done things that are pretty
amazing if we're using certain
medications that are used in other
aspects of life or you know for other
reasons normally it would take a long
time to get it approved for this for you
know for the the virus as we call it so
it would take a long time and I was able
to get such fast turnaround it was
incredible like literally fast because
it was proven safe and it was it's
strong
soft malaria was the disease that one
particular it was spit out for a long
time very very effective on malaria it
may be effective you know what we're
talking about because you've covered it
it may very well be effective with what
we're doing and we're going to find that
soon but the head of the FDA and and
others they gave me really rapid
approvals like how about 24-hour
approvals and we just started having it
in people New York and others are taking
it now and I think we're gonna know
fairly soon whether or not it works and
I think it's got a shot it's got a good
shot you know I gotta give say something
nice I know when you did the Fox
townhall I know that dr. oz was on the
program I've gotten to know him dr. oz
is like me he never goes to sleep he is
talked to more people more doctors more
patients that have tried Hydra
chloroquine and zithromax and you I
don't think you've actually really
explained there is a real trial going on
in the state of New York
right now am I wrong on that well we had
10,000 units supplied and approved and
you know it's a lot and people have been
taking it now for day and a half and we
haven't heard bad news we haven't heard
too much news period but it's a little
early but we're gonna probably know and
again you know maybe it won't work but
we're gonna give it a good shot and why
would we wait normally this process
would take two years to get it approved
even though it's out there in terms of
malaria you know it's out for a
different reason but we have reason to
believe you know we've seen the same
tests I've seen tests and you know in
France and other places Italy so we have
to see whether or not it works if you
were a betting man I guess you'd have to
bet against it but a lot of people are
saying this could be a big answer in
addition to that Gilead and others are
making some incredible things that we're
going to find it it's going to be a
question of how fast when but we've
there are some incredible things that
are going on right now
now the vaccine is going really well but
for the vaccine you need about a year at
least a year of testing because you know
you can't put things into someone
his body by the thousands and then of
its dangers so for that one we're going
to need testing a longer period of
testing but they're making tremendous
progress incredible progress yeah and
dr. oz has been putting on doctors that
have been prescribing off use
hydrochloric win and zithromax and
patients that used it miraculous
turnarounds incredible
I'll say anecdotal and I understand
doctor foul she would would love a
two-year study so what I saw at
everybody but if we can save lives now
and the right to try for me is a freedom
we should have it I know you you've made
that law what have you what are your
doctor and your experts the Surgeon
General dr. foul Chi and everybody else
telling you about convalescent plasma
people have the disease they get over
the disease they have antibodies to the
disease they extract the plasma and then
they infuse it into a very sick patient
what what are you hearing about it well
there's a really positive things I think
you're seeing what I'm seeing some
incredibly positive things and it's you
know affecting them the immune system
and lots of other elements are at work
and you know these are all game changes
by the way show and this is you know
this this really solves a problem I mean
getting a vaccine is important but if we
could do something like as an example if
we had some therapeutically where one of
these numerous items that were testing
right now I mean literally testing it
right now if any of this worked this is
a game-changer and you know there's no
risk when it's already out there in a
different form for a different purpose
so we're going to see how it all comes
out and we're very are just started so
you will probably know before me okay
because you know all of these things and
you you really were up on it but you've
also seen some of the other things aside
from that you've seen some some
incredible potential from other
medicines and we hope we hope we're
going to be able to find it quickly you
know you were very gracious to your
predecessors today in the press
conference because we now know after the
2009-2010 h1n1 virus in that particular
case well the HHS Secretary
to declare an emergency 11 days in it
was a pandemic it's start we knew about
it in April pandemic in June
it wasn't until late October we got a
thousand that Americans we had tens of
thousands of Americans contracted it
ultimately sixty point eight million
Americans contracted it hundreds of
thousands hospitalized I never saw it
not only a government response like this
but the media they praised President
Obama's declaration six months after
they identified it and there was never a
travel ban
well the h1n1 which was Joe Biden is you
know he calls it the n1 h1 but you know
I don't know if that's the big deal but
it's h1n1 this swine flu it's really
known as swine flu as you probably heard
17,000 people died and most people don't
even remember anything happening you
know you see what's going on now you're
not going to be forgetting about this we
close things up we had no choice
it's pretty vicious out there but the
h1n1 swine flu people don't even
remember it but it killed 17,000 people
that's a lot of people a lot
well worldwide it was worldwide it was
almost 600,000 up in this country yeah
in this country or 76,000 yeah you're
right
yeah 17,000 people so that's you know if
they acted very very late they were
incredibly late and the news the media I
won't be a wise guy on your show and
call it what a lot of people know it is
it's so unfair it's so unfair if we
could only have a fair media in this
country our country would be an even
greater place to be but the the media
did nothing to criticize anybody but
I'll tell you a lot of people are giving
us great marks you look at the Gallup
polls and all the different polls that
are coming out we're really being given
good marks for what's happening this is
a very unique time in life it's to see
to see what's going on John 3 a terrible
thing I heard a question and I I think I
know you well enough I've known you for
25 years or so you asked a question how
what number
is acceptable to you and you said none
zero
none and and I wonder I'm gonna scroll
you know I'm bigger my list on the list
person and all the things that you have
done starting with the national
emergency and we mentioned obviously
what you did with the travel ban as you
and it's on the lay for you but is there
anything else you can think of that you
could have done that maybe or maybe
could have done better and and how do
you feel about where we are now
if the pattern doesn't hold because in
China and in South Korea we see the
rapid rise in and people contracting it
and it's gets scary and scarier and
scarier then it plateaus levels off and
then a drop a precipitous drop do your
scientists believe that that will happen
is there anything we could do to make
that happen faster so we can save lives
and people don't get this virus well we
did the banned from China but you
remember we did also abandon it elite at
was another one we were hearing bad
reports and a lot of people were dying
in Italy and I did a band to Italy and
especially certain areas in Italy and
then I did the band to Europe where it
took a lot of Hell and then we did
ultimately the UK and Ireland and you
know we did the rest of it that was
separate from the European Union as you
know and we had to do that because they
started building up in fact they're you
know they're building up quite a bit now
unfortunately so we had to do it with
the UK and and we did that and it was
you know something that by that time and
that was very early by that time I felt
I felt very confident we were doing the
right thing and we did the right thing
otherwise you would have had a lot of
people from Italy coming in and did you
see what's going on in Italy and it's
it's an incredible thing you know when
we did the band over here a lot of the
people went to Italy they went to hit
aliy in Spain a lot of the people from
China but you see exactly what's what's
going on no I think this that we
inherited a broken system from the
previous administrations not just one
and it was very broken it was the system
of tests but Joan it wasn't it
was it meant for millions of people like
we're talking about it was a bad system
for millions of people it was okay the
CDC it was okay for small numbers but
we're talking about something that
hasn't been seen for many many years
this hasn't been seen for decades I
don't know maybe you know the big one
was 1917 and that was the worst by far
that was a vicious that was the Spanish
flu they call it and that was that was
there was really nothing like that what
that did to Europe that way what are
their sections of Europe at a big big
chunk of the United States - that was
the worst yeah you know you've been
asked a lot of questions in recent days
about the defense production Act why I'm
saying this you know I do think that you
know bad times often brings out the
worst and a few the price gougers the
hoarders with all due respect the
Democrats playing games and holding up
this bill for a week really ticked me
off
you were more gracious than me but I'll
put that aside for a minute but all
these businesses are gonna scroll on the
screen have stepped up and offered to
help and you said that you have not had
to you enforce the defense production
Act except for two minor cases you
didn't want to talk about it earlier
today to explain what and what key these
companies are helping the American
people explain this new paradigm of
public and private partnerships and
drive up testing and and everything that
they're doing well there's a tremendous
esprit de corps it's it's like
incredible what's going on the spirit
the the love of our country and we have
something called the defense production
act and it's a very powerful act it's
it's incredibly primary you can do
almost anything as as president you can
demand that they give you whatever you
want I mean all of these things it's a
powerful tool so I haven't had to use it
because like we had Ford step-up general
motors step up 3m step up so many
companies stepped up and they're making
vast amounts of things but you know when
you talk about ventilators that's not
like buying a car
it's a highly it's very expensive it's a
very intricate piece of equipment you
know what it is
heavily computer
you know the good ones are very very
expensive and you know they're today
like Governor Cuomo and others that say
we want you know 30,000 of them thirty
thousand I think of this you know you go
to hospitals that have one in a hospital
and now all of a sudden everybody's
asking for these vast numbers so but we
have now company stepping up and they're
building them they're doing the masks
we've already delivered millions and
millions of myths but remember we're
really a second line of attack the first
line of attack is supposed to be the
hospitals and the local government and
the states the states themselves I mean
we have people like Governor Inslee he
should be doing more he shouldn't be
relying on the federal government
governor Inslee that's the state of
Washington he was a failed presidential
candidate and you know he's always
complaining and your governor of
Michigan I mean she's not stepping up I
don't know if she knows what's going on
but well she does to sit there and blame
the federal government she doesn't get
it done and we send her a lot now she
wants a declaration of emergency and you
know we'll have to make a decision on
that but Michigan is a very important
state I love the people of Michigan what
they do I'm the one you know I bring it
back many many car factories into
Michigan and she is a new governor and
it's not been Pleasant and you know you
look around and you see what's going on
and by the way most governors have been
fantastic I have to tell you most of
them whether it's Democrat or Republican
but we had a trouble we've really had
some trouble with the state of
Washington the governor he's a ninny ran
for president didn't exactly do well he
got zero and we've had a big problem
with the young a woman governor from you
know who I'm talking about from Michigan
so we can't you know we don't like to
see the complaints and I am getting
along with Governor Cuomo I think that a
lot of things are being said that are
more I don't think that certain things
will materialize and you know a lot of a
lot of equipments being asked for that I
don't think they'll need but I'm
building you know we're building for
hospitals for medical centers and many
other things we've developed and sent
thousands of thousands of ventilators
and hopefully they're going to do well
but you know you have to sit this has to
be managed by local government and by
the governor's it can't be managed by
the federal government with that being
said we inherited it largely empty you
know you'd call it a chain or to just
think of it as a big monster warehouses
all over the country but it was largely
again it was broken it was a broken
chain and we're filling it up and we
fill it up very strongly and we deliver
the equipment a lot of the times we have
them go directly to the state so we're
really helping the governor's we had a
call today we're almost every governor
just about I would say all 50 just about
and it was like a love fest they were so
happy with the job we're doing but they
are that front attack because they're
there now in the case of New York in the
case of Louisiana will you have a very
good Governor John bel Edwards but he's
a Democrat and he's very thankful for
what we're doing with doing a hospital
for him we're building these are sort of
portable hospitals but they're
incredible I mean when you see them go
up and it's FEMA and it's the Army Corps
of Engineers and they are incredible
people they can't get enough credit for
the job they do well and I was kind of
angry at Andrew Cuomo I had a great item
on radio for 40 minutes great
conversation I grew up and I was born
and raised in New York and then it's I
need 30,000 ventilators and I'm like
okay it really was annoying me before I
get to the things I don't like in last
night's bill and most a lot of it got
taken out thankfully but I want and
rather than reading everything that's in
it I'm gonna scroll I love lists you
know that the good things in the bill
good in the sense that we're going to
help hospital workers we're gonna help
workers we're gonna help small business
we're gonna help the cruise line
industry the airline industry tell us
what what you like about this it's
unprecedented we've never spent this
kind of money before well as an example
the workers are gonna get $3,000 for a
family of four they get to get all sorts
of things that they prank Lee in many
cases they wouldn't have even gotten if
they had the job if we didn't have to go
through this hell and it's
it's a wonderful thing the problem is
and you see it alright there's right in
front the problem we have is that it's
very very painful dealing with the
Democrats because they're if they ask
for things that they've been trying to
get for 10 years that we don't want to
give but if we don't get him give it we
don't get the 2 trillion dollars that
gets sent out to people the workers that
we don't get the 2 trillion dollars
that's going to really save companies we
have a lot of this money is going to
save Boeing it's going to save the
airline industry and you know that means
not only does it mean what it says it
also it means tremendous jobs we can't
let Boeing go you know Boeing had a
problem big one to start off with and on
top of it this happened and we'll save
Boeing and we'll save the airlines and
we'll save other companies we have
companies that were virtually triple-a
and all of a sudden you're loaning them
money you could call it a bridge loan a
short loan to get over it in all cases
we intend getting the money back getting
into interest and in many cases some
cases issuing what they call warrants
will get pieces of the company large
pieces of the company and that will come
back and inure to the benefit of US
taxpayers I mean they're going to be
great it's a great sting so we had to
give up things that you know you just
instead of just saying let's do what's
right which is taking care of the
workers and making sure these companies
don't go out of business
you could never start them again if the
airlines if you're never going to be
able to start it's like it's a very
difficult thing with the Democrat so we
end up giving them something for Kennedy
Center we end up giving them something
for far worse than that look say what
you want about Kennedy Center scroll
that scroll that I'm gonna put it
because you know the Kennedy Center got
hit hard I mean there aren't too many
people what you guys said today Romeo
and Juliet okay you know kid pretty much
go in because of the what's going on
with the virus but beyond far beyond
Kennedy Center we give things that we
don't want to give you know what I'm
talking about you have them up on your
screen but you have to in order to get
we cut out and you just said it better
than anybody over the last two days we
cut out much of it if you would have
seen some of the things we would
and it's a shame that we can't just sit
down and easily it's always like such a
big deal I mean it went on and on and on
late into the night every night and this
could have been done quickly in one day
the bottom line is we got a 96 to
nothing vote and I think all of the
senators that weren't there were they
were in quarantine and the case of Rand
Paul a good guy by the way he actually
has this problem and I'm sure he'll be
alright I spoke to him today
that's good news for Senator and and by
the way people saying you were joking
about Mitt Romney you want everybody to
get well I'm assuming I'm not a fan but
of course I want him to get well
absolutely yeah we do all right let me
ask you this and I scrolled the bad
stuff I'm more angry than you are but
that's it's more important we focus on
the solutions so we look at the
unemployment claims today it's the
numbers scary yeah I mean 3.3 million
it's not surprising but it's scary we've
watched as I mentioned earlier China
South Korea you get quickly all scary
scary numbers people contracting the
disease scary scary numbers with all
sorts of things and all of a sudden if
the pattern holds then it's levels and
then it drops down completely and then
there's no more new cases all your
doctors telling you every day they
expect that to happen here well I think
we do I mean whether you're doctors are
not you know I'm looking forward to that
day when it levels out and then goes
down and I think we're gonna have a
tremendous bounce look at the stock
market today I think we set a three day
record we set a one day record yesterday
today we almost said it again I mean you
know the stock market's gotten up
tremendously over the last few days and
I think it's for two reasons because
they know that I am one that wants to
get everybody back working you know that
was important people would say yeah
we'll take three or four or five months
and everybody said three or four months
you know our country is not designed for
that and our people aren't designed
we're not engine
for that John where well everybody wants
to go back to work so you know people
they own a restaurant they can't keep
the restaurant closed for months by the
way the sooner we go back the better the
the lift that we're going to get I think
we're going to have a bounce like maybe
you've never seen I just think there's
so much pent-up demand but we have to
get rid of this debt is a possibility
I'll do it in in quadrants in pieces and
you know you can explain that you well
yeah you'll take the farm belt you'll
take certain states that aren't badly
impacted you know where they have almost
none or they have just a little bit you
take a look into some of these great
states and like Iowa you take a look at
i do' and you take a look at nebraska
we'd have a great medical facility by
the way even for this and you take a
look at some states a big portion i mean
they all have a little bit but many of
them have just a little bit and they
have it under control there are
incredible governors their incredible
senators and they're watching it and
they're very very well-run and and they
have it under control they immediately
put the people in quarantine so you know
so you do that new york is a bigger deal
but it's going to go also but i have a
feeling that a lot of the numbers that
are being said in some areas are just
bigger than they're going to be i don't
believe you need 40,000 or 30,000
ventilators you know you're going to
major hospitals sometimes they'll have
two ventilators and now all of a sudden
they're saying can we order 30,000
ventilators so look it's a very bad
situation we haven't seen anything like
it but the end result is we got to get
back to work and i think we can start by
opening up certain parts of the country
you know farm belt certain parts of the
Midwest other other places but I think
that as an example you go to Texas there
are places in Texas great governor Greg
Abbott there are places in Texas where
you know just a tremendously big state
that aren't impacted by this so I think
we can open up sections quadrants and
then just keep keep them going until the
whole country is opened
but we have to open up the people want
to get back to work they want to get
back that's the way we're engineered oh
let me go back to Governor Cuomo and you
said you know what I really did have it
for the first time he's ever done
anything my show we had a good 40
minutes on the air and I I think he's
been in many ways he's done a good job
in New York but that he always reverts
back to whatever y'all put up on the
screen all the things you did for New
York and there's one thing that I
noticed and I don't know maybe this is
uniquely you but I don't think people
really truly understand where do you
think we would have been if the travel
ban wasn't in effect where would we have
been if 10 days after the first case I I
think that one decision was probably the
best from the beginning but I don't hear
anybody on the other side of the aisle
say you know I don't like Donald Trump
but that was a smart idea
probably not only bought us time
probably saved tens of thousands of
Americans from contracting the disease
that was a good call I mean we that
divided as a country you can't
acknowledge where you kill Soleimani you
can't acknowledge killing soleimani
states but leading state sponsors terror
Iran
he leads the state sponsor of terror he
killed Americans in Iraq the divide is
pretty intense well you don't hear too
much you'll hear from Republicans you'll
hear from some Democrats but no we would
add tremendous death tremendous
tremendous death had we not acted early
and our country is getting great credit
for that
you know forget me our country is
getting great but it was a good decision
hey when I made it I was I would say
this is a big that's a big decision you
cut off China and the people coming in
and you talking about tens of thousands
of people no we would have had death all
over the place showing you know that let
me go early on I remember somebody asked
a question about how your younger son I
know you I know your family I know your
older kids I've met your younger son
he's a very is wonderful kid very polite
nice funny and smart and you said you
you asked
what are you telling him about it you
said it's bad where's he now how does he
feel about it and what do you say to
those Americans that they see the
headlines they read the the worst of the
worst you got death counts on TV almost
24/7 or contracting the disease what do
you say to Americans had a very very
concerned worried even fearful about
this well as anybody that the parent
knows he said he's a wonderful young boy
and I have wonderful kids but the others
are old enough they can see and they can
see for themselves but it's very hard
talking about a thing like this because
it's you know it's so negative it's so
it's you know it's just it's death and
you don't you don't like discussing it
and you know you hope they could always
handle it in some way but you know
people are they grow up and nobody
nobody says this does not been anything
like this in this country now swine flu
was pretty bad but it wasn't it wasn't
to the extent of this I I think you
probably have to go back a long ways to
go to this one you know who would think
when I'd read about the I've read about
the Spanish flu that was 1917 which
killed anywhere from they say 75 to 100
million people and it was devastating
and it was also have you had it you had
a very good percentage of not making it
you know it was it was really something
now one thing that I can say that's
really good the mortality rate is much
much better in our way then I was then
people were thinking at the beginning
because you were hearing 3 4 or 5
percent and now with all of the testing
and all of the things that we've now
established great testing that's one
thing I could also tell you it's a big
that's really a big achievement with
we're testing we've tested now more than
anybody but with all of the all of the
testing with all of the cases we're now
fight and you have to remember if
somebody's sick to going to the doctor
therefore it gets reported bad things
can happen to that person but there are
thousands and thousands of people
hundreds of thousands of people millions
where they have it and they don't go to
a doctor because it's not that bad they
have a call they have the sniffles in
some cases they have nothing they have
it
but they literally don't have anything
so when you look at that and then you
see the people who die you take a look
at the people you know I think you're
talking about very significantly under
1% and I think that's a tremendous
that's a tremendous thing now
the flu we lose you know thousands of
people a year to the flu but that number
is very very much under 1% it's you know
1/10 of 1% so this number would be
higher but I think that's a big positive
because when this started people were
talking about 3 4 and 5% now they're
seeing that and it's through the testing
but they're seeing that it looks like
it's substantially below I think it's
substantially below 1% because the
people don't report the only people that
report are the people that are really
feeling sick and those are the ones that
unfortunately sometimes don't make it
let me ask you 222 days mr. president
there will be an election in this
country it looks like it will be Joe
Biden on the other side I'm not sure if
you've had an opportunity to watch his
well let's say technically struggling
candidates struggling whatever he's
doing today he said we hold these truths
etc that's after of course he hold these
truths to be self-evident all men and
women are created by by the thing the
thing are you watching it and what is
your analysis of the things he's saying
and seems to be rather forgetful and
doesn't seem to have a lot of stamina
and doesn't seem to be I say it on this
show I say it doesn't seem to have a
fastball if he ever had one and his slow
pitch seems to be slower than ever well
you know I understand what you're saying
but to be honest I watched his debate
I'll shock you by saying this right I
watched him debating Bernie and it was
pretty much of an even debate he was not
bad at all and you know bernie is not a
bad debater he's in there he's got a lot
of ranting and raving and you know let's
give everything away but bernie is there
are things for a series he's been a
pretty good debater over the years
Bernie and and I thought that that was
you know one of his best nights so I
don't want to really say negative look I
do
just run against them I think I want to
run on my record I don't want to go
against somebody else and we'll see what
happens he's still got that's a long
time you know before you get there
that'll be quite a bit of time we're
gonna have our code read you know we
have our convention in North Carolina in
Charlotte and we are you know definitely
planning it's toward the end of August
and somebody was asking today will you
cancel the convention I said no way I'm
gonna cancel the convince you we're not
going to cancel it's going to be
incredible and I don't know what the
Democrats are the advantages the winner
gets to choose the time of the
convention so I could go first or I
could go less going less is much better
because when you go first and then they
do it so going last is much better and
we chose the second date so we're quite
a bit later than them which i think is
good so we're at the end of August and I
think we're going to be in great shape
long before there then I don't know what
they're gonna do they come up sooner
they're in Milwaukee a great place so if
they don't do it maybe I'll do a speech
there or something we'll do a rally in
Milwaukee where they were going to me
but they now know today I think it's
it's maybe unlikely that they're gonna
do a convention but that's up to them
you said that you will be speaking
tonight a half hour after this program
10:30 Eastern 7:30 Pacific with
President Xi of China we know that this
now is a fact it's indisputable they hid
it they lied about it
Mike Pompeo said China is still not
being forthcoming even went further he
also said Russia's not being forthcoming
and Iran we know the conspiracy theory
that they've been pushing in in China
against the United States I know you
you've said at different times you get
along with President Xi you have this
new first part of this trade deal 220
billion in two years what do you what
are you gonna say about him and
withholding information and moving
forward why did they lie to us well
let's go back first of all you mentioned
Russia Russia's looking like they're
having quite a bit of a problem and
people weren't bringing that up with the
whole thing with a virus Iran we know
about that that's been really really bad
and we've also offered them assistance
we have the greatest in the world we
have the greatest people at this kind of
thing
the world and with China they said that
some of our soldiers caused the problem
we're saying what soldiers what are you
talking about it wasn't by him I don't
believe but nevertheless it got out
there and I started calling it the
Chinese virus and everybody picked it up
and you know I'm not looking to do that
look well it's better to have a good
relationship we have a great trade deal
now finally after many many years should
have been done by Obama and by the way
previous administrations cuz nobody
nobody has ripped this country like
China we you know we were losing four or
five more than that five hundred and
fifty billion dollars a year every year
to China and this went back many many
years so we now have a great piece of
the trade that will start phase two and
that'll be great too it would take it in
billions and billions of dollars a year
in tariffs and they are paying for it
because they devalued their currency and
other things so you know let's get along
with China let's get along with Russia
if we can we'll see if we can do
something with Iran we'll see I mean I
think they want to make a deal I think
they don't they they got a problem but
we'll see what happens when you and
Obama made that deal it was one of the
worst deals I've ever seen you would
help Iran if they would allow help with
the virus secretary of state offered
we've offered many countries including
North Korea including Iran if they I
think it's the appropriate thing to do
and we'll see what happens look we're
gonna see what happens with Iran and I
think they want to mean I think they
want to make a deal I think John Kerry
shouldn't have been speaking that's
called the violation of the Logan Act
but John Kerry has been speaking to them
probably saying wait till after the
election maybe you'll be dealing with
sleepy Joe and you can make it he did
you want same thing with China maybe
China saying look let's wait till the
elections over and maybe we'll be
dealing with a guy whose son walked out
with 1.5 billion to manage they ask you
there's been a lot of speculation i
watch your entire medical team during
the task force meetings
dr. Fauci I think it's served six
presidents you you have some of the best
there is no cut is there a conflict I'll
ask you with either doctor foul chi or
anybody else no I get along with them
great I get along with Deborah
fantastically I look we're all in this
together this is not a question of that
and I get along with most of the
governors I don't like it though when
some governors I mean you know I
mentioned two of them but some of these
governors you know they they take take
take and then they complain they take
and you do a great job you build up my
hospital you do other than they're
always complaining so I don't like that
but generally speaking I get along up
getting along actually very well with
Governor Cuomo you know we have a vote
whoever ship going there and it was
supposed to be in four weeks it's
leaving now on Saturday we were able to
move it up it stopped up with supplies
it's a great ship and you know it's a
hospital ship and it's leaving Virginia
on Saturday and some excites going to
get to New York on Monday it's going to
be docked in New York Harbor and you
know this is a tremendous they're
warships these are ships that take care
of the soldiers and battles and they are
big and powerful and it'll be up there
instead of in three weeks it'll be up
there on Monday how the people that are
around you and I you see people kind of
spread out to the stage and we have
little less than a minute here and then
the first lady in particular I think she
could say almost on a regular basis that
her approval ratings are higher than
yours is that a problem in the family I
think every time I make a speech or have
a rally they have sons we love our first
lady now she's doing a fantastic job
Sean you know that yeah well I know mr.
president I know you've been busy I know
it's up late I know you've been working
hard are got my goal is that every
American we want to save lives in the
interim we want to get a permanent
solution thank you for taking the time
to spend with our audience and and
hopefully we can get this past us as
quickly as possible thank you sir it's
an honor thank you very much John thank
you all right thank you